the following trailer is rated as for
spoilers
[Music]
welcome to korean netflix home of zombie
killers and elaborate headgear and 500
000 shows about shy teens in love but
now catch the intense global sensation
that's making americans whose only
exposure to battle royale concepts is
fortnite and whose only exposure to
korean film is parasite say
i'm getting serious parasite meets four
night vibes from this
squid game
seoul's hottest extreme competition is
squid game this show has everything
dramatic life or death stakes
playstation controller cosplay human
furniture old men soiling themselves
organ harvesting and you can do a human
marble which is a thing where you play
marbles with your best friend until one
of you loses the will to compete
these very different strangers will face
off in a series of children's games for
a shot at 45 billion korean wan which
works out to let's see here i'm gonna
carry the one divided by rotation earth
um about three lindsay lohan fury nfts
but for the losers there's a different
kind of prize piping hot lead
[Applause]
the point is they die
in this colorful hybrid of social
commentary and thriller that invites you
to pass judgment on the creepy dudes and
masks watching all of this go down for
their own entertainment i mean what kind
of sick society would even ask people to
hurt themselves for your entertainment i
mean right ugh gross to even think about
it high five
never mind it's pretty funny
experience the black mirror fanfic that
dares to ask what if the weird
middle-aged people who exclusively read
dystopian y-a have to experience their
horrors first hand and meet gee hun a
stand-in for every male tv writer and
that he's a good guy at heart but a bad
dad he'll get one chance at redemption
if he can win the squid game
unfortunately he's bad at killing
however he is elite at standing next to
people getting killed
but he's not alone fighting alongside
gehan as his childhood friend song woo
apparently the only guy from seoul who
got into college
this grandpa who makes it really far
into the competition because he's the
only one old enough to have played games
outside as a kid
which isn't saying much they don't so
much jump you in as let you stand next
to them while you eat a sad hard-boiled
egg say bio an uncomfortable reminder to
westerners that north korea is a real
place with actual people in it
the wild card who's basically nick cage
reincarnated as a korean lady and some
random dudes who made it into the final
16 we can only assume that all their
horrible but tragically justified at
some point off camera
but while this crew squares off and
ultimate stakes foursquare take a peek
behind the scenes of the most brutal
show to work for since ellen from the
among us crewmates who do all the dirty
work to the financial backers who i'm
pretty sure tommy lee jones from jfk
such a beautiful number
69.
nice together they form pop culture's
go-to indictment of capitalism killing
the poor's for sport or making them turn
on each other for a big prize oh if i
forgot about rat race i would kill my
best friend just a nazi smash mouth live
so strap in for the violent chaotic but
also quietly heartbreaking global
sensation that blessed us with some of
2021's easiest group halloween costumes
proves there's still an audience for
original content if it's you know good
and a truly depressing number of people
relate to being so broke that you'd beat
your childhood bestie to death but no
raising the minimum wage if
jack-in-the-box tacos cost more than a
dollar that's socialism brother
starring
i'm from seoul but i'm not a soldier oh
that's cho seng wu you went to college
at smu for business smart guy
a literal old boy
assistant to the regional manager
sadness everdeen
never squid with crazy
and sensitive thugs y'all need hugs
the bummer olympics
[Music]
oh right there was that whole subplot
about the cop who was infiltrating the
squid game should we go back and like
figure out something to say about him to
tie all this in or
nah
something that i suggest for a change
i've been trying to get you to say one
of my youtube comments for years
roses are gray
violets are gray i am a dog
i'm dr henry killinger and this is my
magic murder bag
see she